hello hello everyone and I don't know whether to say
good afternoon good night good morning
for me it's one in the morning
so it reminds me a lot
of a radio program
that if alone at dawn today
we are going to talk about cryopreservation my
name  from Jorge Stain many years ago it
has something I think preservation a little
over 30 years
well I am going to tell you a little about the
history of the freezing in the
possibilities we have for those who
want my
mail through the clouds later if they want to
communicate rows
waters in the  gmail.com you can send me
all the questions you want
well it
all started with the history of
transgenics transgenics in
the 80's the 90's had just started
but at that time we didn't have these
specific markers like these
animals that are
transgenic and have these  colors
that we identified which forms at
times there were so many and we had to
analyze them in all the tubes, I really
didn't know what to do all of a sudden  they
found animals that there were no longer
places to keep them where to
keep them then in the 90s
the idea of
well-
established preservation in bovines and sperm in
many species began, however in mouse
migration had begun in the 70s
in  the year 72 is its first pérez it is
published today there are
repositories that no
embryo bank worldwide where
animals are exchanged in the usa there is the
mmd rc
in europe of the motto of which I was
lucky to start working with them
from its beginnings and the rhein who
is the most famous in japan
come here gata
but these three are the
majority in south america
unfortunately there is still nothing start
but there is still nothing and this is
precisely where all the existing strains
are and  that have been published and that have
been important that are
frozen today either as an embryo
or as a sperm or as they are now co  How one
can know where these things
are, well, there is an international federation
of mouse resources that simply
with this email that you see here,
this website
that you see here, you
can find the strain that you
are looking for, someone who wants to
do research, no  You have to
reinvent gunpowder, normally the
knockout or something you want is
concentrated on this site
so you can find out if the animal is
frozen by embryo or sperm or
there are only foreigners and all the
variations that exist within the
different types of knockouts,
transgenics
but let's go  to what
our work units are going to do because each
one in their I tell you of an animal facility or however
they want to say, depending on the countries
that you belong to, they
will have a laboratory attached to the
animal facility worth terio of which
could have the
reproduction techniques  assisted that will help a
lot in the management of that animal area
simply to manage  the endocrine
you can do the derivation of
rats and mice expel all the
same techniques the embryo bank
what I am going to explain to you today will also
be phishing which is a quick freeze you
can do when you go up through the in vitro station
the expansion of  the colony has
requested the count and he did not experience the
fact of managing that wanted so they
manage the spaces and in turn the
costs
old or dead animals can be recovered
I am not going to talk about the
dead animals today but I can tell you that
up to five days after the  dead if
they keep it in a refrigerator at four
degrees the sperm continues although even
the ovaries but three days after
death a transfer can be made
and well in recovery he is
interested later after talking I was thinking of
saying it they have new needs
and obviously if there is already  set up a
transgenic production laboratory all the rest is very easy
because they are the manipulations that are
there  but if the manipulations are learned
it is also easy or
simpler it can make new
transgenic animals be it a mouse mouse logos in
any other species likewise the
production of congenital
is also the basis of
in vitro fertilization and other alternative models
and it can become power  and he wants to, he
can't even produce an
alternative model as a laboratory animal
when breeding began.
davies whittingham and family,
in 1972 they published the first
paper in the science magazine on
embryo freezing
and from then on all the
species that you can imagine have emerged
and always maintaining the basis
of embryo freezing with which they
began to communicate  to freeze
eight cell embryos because eight
cells 8 are one simply because
you  In the laboratory, half of the bastoneros are killed
,
each one of these is a homer blast, there are
techniques that if they have an embryo with two
cells, they were to separate them and they will
understand identical twins in a day, eight
cells will have these these man blasts,
those that also  they could
separate them
, however,
the idea that you want to use
is simply that it is a very good
indicator of the manipulation that you
have done in the laboratory because the
idea is that the embryo ends up with all
its cells intact and they kill half of
something that has  In the past, a
bad freezing process is usually bad with a
bad thawing process.
Actually, you suffer more from
thawing than from freezing,
but
both are only harmful because of the
intoxicants
that we can freeze today, we can
freeze what we are going to talk about not
only  of embryos because it is very
simple the embryo the embryo is simple
because of many characteristics
simply because it has  in the entire genome
of the line and whose freezing is in
the embryo dance
if we are going to freeze the way today it is
very fashionable due to cost problems
we simply have to do an
in vitro explanation later and then an
area transfer or use xxi
which brings certain others also
because manipulation or artificial insemination is very difficult,
which works
quite badly in rats and mice
and what I am going to talk about finally is
ovarian freezing, which in turn can
be transferred to the ovary, this is
extremely important when it is not  They can
get sick so they
can't get it so we deliver so
to maintain a strain in which the
females are lucky and
freezing locals
today too then I'm going to give you
the data the doctor don't do so well
just home  publish two but not for the
first time a viable method
of oocyte freezing to be able to make
a white of oocytes in this
case instead of ovary could t  work
known
oh
him
what are the advantages of an entity bank
but they are already many, many
not only the economic means of
raising the vines that are not used
because it is close to hitler to keep
an animal alive
that is, they have practically there are many
good me  They are saying that you cannot
see the other places
and
that you cannot economically maintain
the animals that are not used
frequently
and in that regard,
imagine that you understood me, the
ymad alive in a box in an animal facility
can cost between a dollar and a dollar.  and a
half to two depending on the subsidies that
you have to handle the
air animal once it has to be
frozen is simply the cost of
liquid nitrogen that will vary
terrestrially the number of you the
number of embryos which is actually
very very low  the calculations we have
done on a jackson at the time
were about 10 cents per
year the cost of maintaining  If it is a frozen strain,
then the real costs are
very low, very low,
but obviously it facilitates international shipping and
exchange, since
we saw ourselves keeping some
frozen embryos and sending errands of animal origin.
the efficiency of
the diversion network because the
diversion network is actually a series of
washings of the same embryo to eliminate
the contaminants
then and the most important of all
this of the advantage of embryos is that
the frozen animals are not going to
contract any  type of disease they are
going to kill me they are going to have any type
of genetic contamination because they are not
going to be managed in that type of
way and there are really many
advantages in keeping the aesthetic
very verifiable since once they are
frozen under nitrogen and
liquids they
exist  which are 196 degrees below zero
there is the possibility of a
point mutation every 10,000 years due to the  There is little
radiation, it is as if it were a
ship in space,
but there are many myths about embryo freezing,
there are many, when it
began to freeze, everything froze, it
was freezing and half the
slow freezing that dropped to three
degrees per minute until the  minus
eighty and that is a
nitrogen injection that not only takes about
two and a half hours in three but the
noise of the nitrogen injection in the
term today the most convenient for
large production is the two-
step freezing this freezing  two steps is
a school slow freezing was
normally done
in tubes and two-
step freezing in straws similar to what is done
in bovines and what dies in humans
is called two-step
because it has both systems have the
embryo  and in turn it has the diluent
that will make the osmotic diluent to
eliminate the protesting kilo of the
cells
so at the time of
thawing that shakes  grandmother, as
if it were a thermometer, the
two solutions are mixed and it is a very fast way
to do it.
rapid freezing is a freezing
that is made with liquid nitrogen vapors
that we are eliminating from
freezing in two passes that
an alcohol machine needs  quick freezing
and already uses only
nitrogen vapors and a method that
works very well what today is
ideal and that most
people use is vitrification the only
problem in duty is
that vitrification you have a solution is
extremely  dense and in which it becomes
very difficult to manipulate the embryo
after that
the results are stupendous
actually in any of the methods
with which they work we have to
talk about 80 to 90 percent
survival that each ticket survival is a
story too  of the strains today we have
heard a good talk from formal de
benavides who has talked about
genetic characteristics and that each  I
had one on the neck, I am going to repeat a lot
of what they say,
these are techniques that are very simple,
but mouse genetics is going to play
tricks on us.
Vitrification comes from the name of the
Bible, that is, when we talk about
freezing, it has to do with it.  a formation
of ice the formation of
ice crystals are essential for
a directly solid solution to form
in vitrification
freezing is so fast that you pass the
physical aspect of freezing to a
glass formation hence the name
peter windsor vitrification as deficient  He was one of
the fathers of all these theories and he,
as a physicist, was the one who
had the impression of
the design and let's say of the different
freezing is what a slow freezing is
in which the cell has the
possibility
I'm going to use this arrow again  the
possibility of dehydration eliminate
water balance with the environment because
then the idea of ​​a cell is the
exchange between the environment  externally
and internally
we know from the laws and the
first Nobel Prize for which he
discovered that 80 percent of the
cell was water so here they play
with those principles eliminating water and
putting a protective cryo that
is normally useful in  glee with zeal or dimethyl
sulfone that lowers
the destruction point of cold
so it is exactly the same as
we do with cars in ice areas
where antifreeze is added
to the radiator in the
cell and we change the medium so that it
is not destroyed  if we leave the water inside
the cells these ice crystals would
form inside the cell as
shown in this quick cell so
what happens that
would kill or destroy the organelles in the
cytoplasm and there would kill the
cells instead if we go to a
super freeze  fast as vitrification the
formation of crystals is so small
because it does not give it time to form
those are the three principles that they
use
it is not for the cont
In fact, any of the stages can be
implanted from play implanted can
be frozen from the first cell
with two pronuclei ideal for making
transgenics and 12 of which I
like is eight cells add love
when we reach the blastocyst
freezing is much more difficult
It can only be done by
vitrification obviously this is
hacking when here we already have a
stem cell coming out here we will not be
able to freeze anything good it will not
be viable but up to here I
mean the little mouse if it can be frozen
each one has its  advantages and
disadvantages
you want to freeze it is 8 servers you
have to wait for the embryos to
reach 8 cells to be able to
collect them so they are already 34
days old the animal sitting in the animal facility
waiting for this and instead
what he calls the spirit feeling that  It is
a method that we had started in the
jackson that is a modification of the
renar and binner in the
freezing system pe  but everything is based on guest
fertilization so the
idea here is
super mule and one female
for every male that you should use
five to ten females
in vitro fertilization is done they collect all
the embryos you want
and then it is frozen in this  stadium
is much cheaper than the rest and
much more directly by thawing they
obtain the two cells and then they
simply do an
embryo transfer and they will have the line it
is quite simple as long as
in vitro fertilization can be used
as a base weapon for any freezing
It is also more comfortable with two
cells because
embryo transfer is the link and that is much
simpler than later waiting for the
blastocyst to have to be seen in
the nucleus.
Now, as with all wonders, they have their
problem,
someone is going to want to deceive us, they have a
cache like  says English and this is this
from the book
of mouse genetics in which, as
reported  do spoke each strain will have
its reproduction marked
the reproduction index of the strains
is basic you cannot have a
waltz the one that has 10 young does not exist that
will not be balce and will have a
number of mating that will be
null
of this it is known that they came here
marked as relative and fused
that effect then
means that so many times it will
mate so many times
each industrial strain will remain is characteristic
of these people
and the same in a work that
is from 2010  and we have done we have
shown that by comparing
transgenic mice of the same base in which they
work with 657 care where science
57 if it should not say see 6 if they are the
blacks of 657 there are various colors and they
are not only black
and it
changes depending on the transgene that  As
we know very well that there are not 2 transgenes or
transgenics nor are they not the same, they
modify the genetic base of the other
two, be very careful when someone asks you to
mind freeze the mouse  that is in
the black strain in the white strain
you have to be the experiment
with the animal to realize what
the reproduction index of that animal is,
do not take it for big as they say in
English for sure because it does not exist
and in this aspect  here we
show that taking an animal saves
this is the altar and all these are
transgenic in that each one will all be
transgenic that were
derived from the eye is none I have had a
fertility problem in it and none
had the same fertility as the walt
ice lo  We can say the same about the
reveal strain that the transgenics are
totally different from the original strain
if we continue with the tables of that same
work here you will see that the
differences are seen even in the response
in super ovulation so
here for example we have
animals that occur
safely between 32 to 25 there is a
very very big difference in how they
respond to the same amount
of pmt hormones that we had  s and
that is not a problem that you
normally sometimes ask me
I have a problem with the hormone and
why don't we look first at the
genetic basis that we are working
the same and here doing a little
proposing nothing but when we are going to do
the  derivations which is a chapter of
6000 that we wrote and the book came
out two years ago but in ie 7
exactly the same great look when
we go to reader and bar because everyone
can have their controversy and before
when we collect embryos and
we can have  Many of us have to think
that what we transfer will not
do 100%, so things
will depend a lot on the strain, even
if we work, we are
going to sperm and we have left aside the
time of the high bond as we see it
here from the time
in which dad put the seed in the
mother's womb no longer exists
now what happens but we continue
working
with something that is very very small and that is
going to have a lot of problems without  However,
the most advantageous thing is your cut
with two masters, you already have all
the strains frozen and protected
, so that is why it was done very, very well
and the graphing
of the sick preservation sieve took off, on the other hand,
three do not have to formulate when doing so
you have nothing in this because they freeze
the sperm and the same story of
protecting the strain against possible
diseases or genetic contamination
again you do not need this
nominal element you are going to work with few
animals because there are three males
obviously the only option when
females  they are of low fertility but
rope great comic to buy that is from floyd that is to say
that you have half
of the chromosome of the cell
what is the problem the problem is that
when you have to reconstitute the
strain you need something that is
similar to the  strain where to start if you
are not going to create hybrids and go back to the
original strain of involving many
crosses and a lot of work then
again  or when they ask for sperm freezing, look
at what it looks like, for
example, if it has a genetic base of
129, sperm freezing is a serious problem
because the reproduction of
129 is great in Vigo great
relatively great because they are born
but in vitro it is produced in embryos
but then, well, it does the transfer,
little mind, it doesn't do anything
and then there will be no effect, it's that they
look closely, they're not going to freeze anymore, they
have to do a
confinement and post-freezing check
and I'll tell you about this because if they
thaw something bad is going to  It would be worse
when they thawed it, without a doubt
many spermatozoa would always die
in freezing
and secondly, more than anything, it
doesn't mean anything,
the size of the spermatozoa is
very small compared to what
the embryo is
if we take the bear all this
mass when  freezes of the 273 know
that it can compress and expand and
remove water in a smooth
r  Suddenly there is no water and what he has in his
head is only a
message march from near that has all the
genetic information so that one
cannot play too much and if we
do not see the problem of the neck here,
that is, it is where  join the tail to the
head are all the
energy base in all the
mitochondria that are going to give energy to
the diseased tail and that is what is going to
break a lot with freezing
and the continuous but wrong my mom said it
does not mean  absolutely nothing here
you have a study from the year
in which
we have a hybrid strain
this is a workhorse for
anyone who wants to do experiments
because frankly they need it in the middle
of the crop I believe that
in vitro fertilization in Coca-Cola
works and  it always comes in 80 to 90
percent this is also an indication
for when they read a work they see what
you know it is made from because there are strains that do not
indicate anything at all because of the
ease  Thus,
the spermatic contours here
are quite even between the lines
when we talk about the 657 of l 6 j there is
an impressive dispersion
and in the pp also in one hundred 129 note
that it is one of the ones with the highest
amount of
concentration spermatozoa and yet it is one of
the least fertile also the worst
of all these observed
but it is not an indication consistent with
what we have to look for fertility
really see if fertilizing is not
used because they dance and that they
move well  It does not mean that they are
fertile
and then from there about 12 appointments were going to be created
long ago by the year 2000 with this
study of the different formats there are
from the counts esper Tuesday and the
genetic base there was already a study
that seemed very  It was interesting that the
combination of the gametes was and in this
aspect here if they can be seen
when we speak in this line it is when
the oocytes were used, that is, the
mother of the 57,000 and the sperm of the
hybrid is well counted
in this case in the second case here
the sperm of the 657 n 6-6
costa and the hybrid embryos are used
and in the third case it
is both, that is, it is the the  crossing
where I want to say that this is
what indicates the fertility of the jungle
none of the others if you want something if
you ask it will be a lot notice that it is
curious that the sperm of the valse is the
one with the least fertility
that comes all the time  The study is from 2000 and we have
continued to do fertilization genetic studies a
lot but when
we began
to freeze sperm with the
famous skim milk and 3 per 7 17
% of Ralph's 18% and we used 3 percent
skim milk  That was the basis of the
studies in the house but it did not dominate the load
until when he published the first papers
in the years
97 128 it was that nobody could repeat it
and that is why at Jackson many many
forces to break down all the work and
we have done it  or to work
, that's why people keep talking
about my method when in reality it was
the loading method, we
had fine-tuned it but the big problem
was that the 657 of us could never
have it, we had 5 percent
fertility  and that's how everyone
density of this doesn't work and it doesn't
work for gas it
was like that in
2008 jackson takes out the famous meter of veins
air cyclodextrin as an antioxidant
and he talked about the traditional methods
that these little oranges that they have there was
my method  and the green one was theirs and
that they compared with it
the myth of / it is a method that works
very well that works very well
but there are always variations of strains
as you can see however
and what I am very interested in
showing you is a method  of tarot that
which ends now in 2012 but it is the
method of the coil charge is where
practically all the strains
have a fertility is your downfall
compared to the fresh one  frozen
the freezing method is similar to
what we were shooting before with
skimmed milk and racing ocha
with
an anti-western additive but the secret and it
was even more in
in vitro fertilization when
using cyclodextrins
here
you
the works these  which are essential
very important and I emphasize this
site if you can copy it
here I have another where does this come from if
you are going to have access to all
the
works here
and I do not have the correct link
oh
more then here on this site  you
will find yourself in your manual from
what reproduction in mice and all the
freezing techniques that a pleasant master
stay
at the moment I am working with
Naomi as a teacher in most of her
courses to have a course now in
September at the university the face  In
a martial woman bass, it is a very
intensive one-week course where you can demonstrate
all your terms.
Well, once
we finish, we are going to go through  how the matter of
daily freezing came up here after a very hot
summer day in bar harbor
by the way lying on the
beach thinking why we received
animals like this
that died in was to freeze
embryos but the animals died more than
two months of keeping them in stables
for  the number of tumors that appeared
then was impossible directly
exceeded molar these animals there
had to be a possibility of
freezing some embryos because
in the jackson keeps know being
bred simply by transforming
ovarian transplants they were
established in the year 57 and for sure a
paper from the  science magazine in this regard
in which all the soups that have
histories of childbirth problems
change the ovaries some containers
that stain the h
two h 2 antigens so there is no
rejection by the ovary
and having these techniques is having the
possibility of freezing  as it happened to
freeze the ovary so we
had the strain
that we collected from  We examined the ovary and
we cut each ovary into one piece of meat,
so they had four pieces of ovary
for each animal,
using Jackson's resources, the
ones 11 used were the same soup of
another color, that's why we used 57 and
white guti 257 to make the recipient of
an ovary that was black or brown
and then it only has half an ovary
here one or more tony's are made to total
rather on one side it is ovariectomy and on
the other the ovary is removed taking
care not to destroy the bag
the ovary is placed in half  of the ovary in that
course and then it mates and at 40 days
the pups begin
and that was based on a
slow freezing with ms or 1.5 starting with what
occurred to me was to use the same
technique as embryo freezing
to have  the same cycles and then it
was easy to make it easy to be able to freeze
everything and because it worked very very
well
this is the surgery that I have come from
from the second edition of the
em manipulation bible  embryo but with an
error in use because an entire ovary is never used
but what is used
is half of the ovary and to understand it is
much easier to put it back in the
bag. Imagine that when you have this
bag and want to remove the embryo this
collapses  so when they collapse, they
can't put it back, placing
half is much easier
and this is a mouse ovary after
freezing and thawing obviously the
books say that
all the big and
x secondary milestones practically prove it in
this case when you can  see that
they are disconnected from the base here
we have the oocyte in the center and these
would be the cells of the follicular theca
my follicular practice comes
all the communication proteins
of who is going to grow who is going to
pit time fly who is going
disappearing is all the communication of
that through the cells of ethics
movies continue if it is disconnected as
in this case here it dies why
directly  entity nothing remains connected and
it is going to be tied and there are
small films that have happened is if we continue
in evolution by putting it in the
embryo transfer surgery it is a
very simple surgery because there is no
reconnection of vessels or arteries or veins
In all of this, the bag is simply opened
as if it were a small bag, the ovary is dropped
and there because of the blood clot and it will
form, we are going to do it instead and
there and
after 24 hours if we do a
methodology it is  As in this case we are
going to see that it is lost in blood
but it is simply a passive diffusion
of the blood within the organ, it did not
change but we also see that in 24 hours
not all of them are dead because these are little
bears,
whether they are secondary but we have their
milestones  primaries that are small, as in
this case, and we arrive after
24 hours at 3 days
and I have how it has grown and not
only that it has grown but that
we see there in the cells there is mitosis, which
means  that this is totally alive
and working and after four months after
several oscillations, note that this is
what was formerly called the
graph follicle today partial follicles or
with follicular liquor arrived for their ovulation
not
in 2010 this method
of freezing is already there  sending them the ovaries
had become a bit obsolete and a
problem because previously no one
sent to read embryos if
everyone uses it in straws then it
occurred to us to
change the method to the outside method
and then this is what we are going to
counting the grandmothers,
the schools, there are two types in a
quarter of a cubic centimeter, the common one that
is used for freezing
sperm and embryos, and there is another, slightly
larger, half a centimeter,
public, 500 cc, which is the one we use to
place the ovary.  and from then on in the
same way of the two steps that
this counter has
this is how we freeze the toilet
the female
is exactly the same as the paj  uela in
the one of half a cubic centimeter but the
protective cold
instead of having desire we used two
molars of propylene glycol plus 10%
yoro feta something came in the middle of less
these two elements are the same as
with desire the only difference that
occurred to me  propylene glycol smells like killing
liquor and in the lowest molecular weight
therefore the first rapid section and is
eliminated faster from the organ
why
in the transfers both doing them
with three in English six years doing
paired experiments with
the same amounts of vials and
straws
and using  plus more recipients for the
parochials the amount of 50 times is
similar
is similar then large differences in the
number of pups born was still
better on straw
and the pups per female were much
better frozen on straw
than what the writing intervals
mean since the  moment in which
the ovary was implanted to when the
first calf was born, which are normally in
the 40 days  It's been a month
and why a month because more or less a
week of respect for the surgery
what does she have to have until
she recovers normally
to start it up
and this has worked calmly very
well
well I think very quickly so
we have thank you very much  I
'm going to write my email again to everyone here
for any doubts that none of them
have, none of them ask, then it's
thought about
and we'll take the opportunity
to ask questions if there were any.
Well,
thank you very much everyone
has the questions to
answer them by mail with  anyone and
you who want to accept thank you
and here someone asks me if that
unique inclination
and for the time transport it is convenient to
project mizar on both sides of the
receiving female before completing
half or quarter of several donors and the
answer is yes yes because it is
shown that you leave part of
one worth or not damage and then put in
the other
the body will respond first with the
ovary  healthy and it will not let the
new implanted work
in the same way as the however
if you study the ovary only the new one will
replace the rest of some other ovary
so that there are no organic competitions it is
convenient to remove both
and here I have another extremely question
It is also interesting
because the ovaries cannot be verified
and if it can be verified from now on,
if it can be verified,
the vitrification problem is that the
pieces of ovaries are smaller
and there are some new techniques that are
trying to be the average user, but they do not
have  the same result, the problem
then is to remember that the
number of bears
and they are born in the female is limited and it will not
grow anymore, there is no constant production
like oid formats,
so if we do not use at a
certain age
a portion of a  moderate millimeter of
ovary to be able to verify what
is then a problem
well
then with this I say goodbye to everyone and
I thank you very much for your attention
and